As individual women,
all of us have experienced
very public relationships.
It's really hard for me to
let my guard down,
but it's time to kinda take the bricks down.
I'm just looking for that zing,
that spark,
something I can't shake.
Damn! 21 men???
You're gonna have to pray for us.
My goodness!
This process isn't for guys
who get intimidated.
You like nipple clamps, sis?
I'm open to it.
We could write some songs together, man!
We gonna have to!
Making you smile is what matters to me.
Does he make
your spirit jump
or your ******* jump?
I don't know if he's genuine.
You're not working hard enough.
I told you that to your face.
I want it to be the real thing.
It is not going to be easy
to become a King
to one of our Queens.
So that door is open?
Oh that door is wide open.
Ooh!